sitting in front of me on first class
from Dallas to Dublin was the actor from
Billy Elliott I was geeking out a little
bit because as far as father son stuff
that's the first real movie that I can
remember just weeping like a [__] I've
never even seen that movie oh dude it's
so much good fatherson stuff but um he's
forever Billy Elliott and um when he
walked in front of me I was just like be
she goes yeah I go that's Billy Elliot
she goes okay I said I'm I'm going to
turn on the mov
she was like do not watch Billy Elliott
you're behind Billy Elliot and I was
like no no but that way maybe if he
walks by me and he sees me watching
Billy Elliott he'll be like I'm Billy
Elliott she was like that's the exact
opposite of what he'll do she was like
no no he's gonna think you're a stalker
yeah he'll see you watching Billy Elliot
and then he'll go oh no I think he knows
I'm Billy Elliot